Okay Marco, you got an answer for me?
>> Yeah, yeah. I, this is, the way I was thinking about
it was essentially, well for the theta min. Wait, so we're maximixing, right?
>> yes.
>> All right. So theta max, then, is going to
be the largest value if, that f can return.
>> Yep.
>> Which is actually the optimum
of the function. So that probability distribution
assigns a probability of well one, if there's a unique optimum, it'll decide
a probability of one to that single point.
>> That's exactly right, but you were getting at something else when
you said if there's one optimum. What if there are multiple optima?
>> Then it's uniform over all of them.
>> Right. So, it is the distribution that generates
only optimal points. So, it's a distribution over optima,
which is just you said and we'd accept optimum
point or anything that sort of captures this idea.
>> Okay.
>> Okay? Well, what about theta submit?
>> So, if it's the minimum that the function can
achieve then it, it ought to be the case that everything
in this space of X's is part of that. So it
should assign uniform probability to all points in the input space.
>> That's exactly right. So it is in fact, simply, the uniform distribution.
>> Nice.
>> Now, this is going to be pretty cool, because in this,
in this slide right here we basically have the mimic algorithm.
>> I'm not seeing it.
>> Well I'm about to tell you, we
are basically going to try to estimate this particular
distribution; P sub theta of X. We're going to
start out with P sub theta of min, P
sub theta min of x, which is the
uniform distribution. So we're going to sample uniformly from
all of the points, and then somehow use those
points to do better and better, and better and
better estimates until we get from uniform to a distribution
of only the optimal points. And that's the basic idea.
>> So, okay, so, and, and the first one being something that's really
easy to sample from, because we're just sampling uniformly from the input space.
>> Right.
>> And the second being something that'd
be really useful to sample from, because if
we could sample from the set of optima, it's really easy to find an optimum.
>> Exactly. So we'll start out here. And we're, the goal is to start
out here and then to end up here. Gotcha.
>> And so let's actually write out a out rhythm that's does that.
>> Yeah, because that's not an algorithm that's just a goal.
>> But many algorithms start out as goals.
>> Hm.